ROBERT KUBIS: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see GCP
Database Migration Services,
then stay tuned because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Migrating your on-premises
databases to the cloud
is a fantastic way to reduce
costs, improve reliability,
and expand your scale.
But the process of moving
that data isn't always
straightforward, which is why
our teams here at Google Cloud
have some best
practices to share.
Dominic Preuss walks you
through the three main stages
of data and infrastructure
migration-- assessment,
migration, and
validation-- each of which
have their own specific nuances.
Let's start with
assessment where
it's important to first
discover all the information
about your data, including
what you're planning to move
and what dependencies
are involved with that.
Then you need to learn about
the capabilities of the cloud
platform services you
are moving to in order
to understand feature priority
and performance, at which time
you can finally data mine
the right path forward
for your migration.
Now once you have
completed your assessment,
it's critical to evaluate
for each of your databases
what migration type you do.
This includes looking
at each database
and asking questions
like if you still
need it, if it should be
replaced by another system,
rehosted, refactored,
revised, or even rebuilt.
This helps you plan on
exactly the type of work that
needs to be done for
each of your databases.
Now from a more
practical perspective,
it's important to ask
yourself whether or not
your database can
handle downtime
during a migration process.
For example, if you can
stop writes to your existing
database, export your data to
a resource like cloud storage,
and then import into
your new database,
then this is going to be a
less complicated and rather
straightforward process.
To speed up offline
migration, the talk
touches on a couple of
performance hacks you can do.
In short, optimize your schema,
choose powerful instances
for your import,
and monitor progress
to adjust along the way.
If you can't allow for
downtime, then you'll
need to rely on replication
to get the job done.
This is where you replicate
your data to the new database.
And once the data is
fully replicated--
meaning the lag between the
old and the new database is
minimal--
you can simply do a scheduled
failover towards a new database
with no or minimal
downtime incurred.
If you do a
heterogeneous migration,
there are a number of
partner applications
that can help you with
the live migrations.
Once you have
migrated, it's finally
time for the validation
step, which first includes
ensuring that all the data
has come across properly
and then validating that
your performance and cost
expectations are still accurate
with your new cloud-enabled
databases.
If you're interested in more
information about migrating
from Cassandra to Cloud
Bigtable or Cloud Spanner,
as well as a great customer
profile with many live demos
on how they accomplished
database migrations,
then check out the full talk.
Links, as always, are in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube channel
for more "Next Rewind" content.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]